Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier, and welcome back to Cuphead. Now,
we've made [a] quite a bit of progress so far, but things are getting harder and harder every step of the way.
But that doesn't mean that I'm gonna give up or take it easy on myself.
I actually am good at shmups, which is something that people don't tend to believe. Hey, another--
Oh! Porkrind! Is that you, buddy?
[Porkrind] Welcome!
Oh, God you don't need to scream to me like that. Okay, but what's good about
this, is nothing because I don't want anything from you even though I'll probably have to buy it eventually
(Inhaling)
Yeeaaggghhh-
Precision is key. I mean that's pretty cool. I like the
Uh... Uh duh duh duh duh duh
Everyone was--everyone was on about the lobber, so I'll get that but that doesn't promise that I'm gonna use it. [Porkrind] Goodbye!
Bye!
Heh, see you buddy. So I just need to explore around find another boss and get right into it. Where are you, you sacks of crap?
Ah do-do-do-. Ah good, another area. "Funfair Fever"!
Okay, that sounds bad, but I'll go for it, I guess. If I actually remember how to play the game which is probably not true.
Do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do, I'm on it - AUGH I don't like it already. Yeah. No, thank you.
Eeyup I don't trust that huyigh-! Oh, hey-. OH!
That is-. Ughah! Well that's horrifying! Ugh! No, parry! I tried so hard. No- AGHH! I can't parry you. Ah, man-
Well, that was a terrible start to a terrible terrible terrible run. All right, hang on-
Yeah, yeah, whatever go away. A-boing- A-boing- Haboosky- Hablonky-
-That's a parry! WOW, did that work at all? I have no idea.
Ugh-yeegh- u-agh! Agh- AGHH- It chased me-
The bean chased aawuagh-
I TRIED to parry! I tried!
Maybe I shouldn't actually try to parry That's probably where I'm making my first mistake. Alright, here we go you got this one. Aiyeegh-
Aiyeegh-
Slap! Slappa! Ah come ON!
If I don't- d- if I sl- ndghih- if I don't slappa them do they still ughaghAGHah- oh, God. I'm not- OH
You know what? AH- the BEAN!
AGHH! God, the BEAN!
All right fine. I'm gonna stop dickin' around here
I'm just trying to be fancier than I really am which is always my first mistake.
Oh! UH
Why! You cornered me. You sack of shit.
Oh well...tits to you
Slappa! God damn it. Slappa don't work on you. Well, uh, it doesn't work if I display my-
stupid head in your ass which is usually my go-to strategy for any time I'm feeling nerrvous.
Okay, no.
Okay, slapa NO AWWH
I just- BEH AAH
SLAPPA! It doesn't work! What kind of slappa bullshit is that!
Alright, fine, I don't need you anymore.
No.
What? If I hit the ball?!
God, I thought if I hit the
ball would have bounced on it or something all right, whatever, okay there we go.
Whoa, nope. Going away, running away, runnin anyway. Slappa, but I'm running. I slappa and then I runna. WHA
Oh jeez
AEGH
NO
You sack of shit.
NOO
God damn it, god. I don't know why these balloons are getting me.
I killed all the bosses like, in no time at all and these fucking balloons.
Nope, God!
Why didn't I go over the stupid thing? I don't want to slappa you.
(Screams in agony)
(whispers) God..
It's a little too early to get angry, this is the first video
I'm recording today, and I really don't want to get grumpy about it. I really don't.
That's the last thing that I want to do right now. OOh NO
Slappa. No, no. Okay, Sally slappa needs to
AGHH
Ehhhy
No Stop, Stop, Ehhh Stop
EHH
St-AGGHH C'mon I was through thaaaaat
You sack of garbo-NOOO
God, you sack of shit. I hate you so much.
You stupid. I'm a slappa de the shit out of you!
Okay, wait Hang on.
Ah, Ah
Get dat combo. Oh hell yeah. Ooops all right, all right.. slapping this boo-AHHHG noo
I was just goofing it. I was just goofing it. Ah stupid piece of poop. Maybe if I don't shoot the balloons they won't poppa.
Oh It's me shooting them that makes them poppa. I'm a stupid. It was all my fault.
Oh
Slappa. Augh. I ain't slapping you that hard. Alright. NO. Okay.
AH!
NOO!
Oh, my god. That was so close. AAGGH!
Okay, firing is now back on. Game on. Oh, you can't die. That's why you'd be so douche.
Ah.
Is this whole place just better if I don't shoot anybody? Maybe that's like the thing.
I don't know what these are all about and I don't like it. Oh no. Oh no. No no no no
AGH! Okay, all right this seems horrible. Why is this even a thing?
Slappa!
NO!
I was slappading!
(Screams) NO!
I was slappa! (Screams) NO, please!
I'm barely slapping alive.
No!
I was slapping. I was slapping.
Ugh. God.
I don't know.
Okay.
So, just don't shoot.
I- See the problem- My problem was, I was killing everybody in this lovely circus when in reality I was the evil one. He's just trying
to catch my fall, help me along. Everything's fine. This guy's just trying to show me some mAAHgic.
I'm just killing everybody indiscriminately which is awfully a horrible thing to do. This is just a fun dunk tank and yet here I am,
murdering.
Dead. Dead.
Excellent. That's what I wanted. Sure wish I had my spread shot,
That would be perfectly useful here, very incredibly useful. God, that spread shot is incredibly-. Whoa! Hey, you
Sons of tits needa-stahp it. Nah nah hey yeah yeah just get out of here
All right there we go. Okay. We're making it. We're doing it. Hiyaa
Shit, I just made it hard for myself. Ha! No! Noo!
I was fine and then I goofed it
I'm such a tit sprinkle. Oh, I don't know what you are, but you're gonna get shaht
From a - Ah! Why? That seems hardly fair - no no
Eeuugh
No, no why are you shoo - why're the -poor flock of ducks. Just going by. Okay, you're the murderer here, that's not me
Oh that seems- oh, up here? Okay.
All right, snuh...
Sna...snaaa...
Snaa-cuhh...
Sna- aughh, that's gross
AHH
Nah nah nah nah nah nah nah nah nah nah nah nah
Not today not today not today not today not today. I'm- I'm watching you. I'm watching you, baby
No. No! Who's doing it? Snack, snack-ree, sna-cree-tions
Snackreats? Snaaa-treat. I don't remember what it was saying befo- eww, gross
Stop that!
Just stop!
Stop being you!
Good God just stop there we go
Okay, there. We go oh
Yeah, that took way more effort than it ever should have I'm very sorry everybody that that should have gone much more smoothly than that
But it did not. Oh wait I get
Ya
Terrible all right bad. Oh, yeah
Mmm. Yeah, probably gonna get a C+
I'll take it
Okay, whatever hello you can't catch me unless you take a shortcut. That's what some punk kids did last week
It's only the only way that could have beaten me to the rides
So maybe you could show me where the shortcut is you're around here. Oh, No, maybe whoo what is this?
What are you a VI reaction? Okay? Sure whatever sure yeah, it's gonna go well for me. Oh boy
I'm up you want bombs you want bombs oh?
Yeah, Bravo. Oh you got a pride. Okay. You got a problem, and I don't have the solution cuz my solution core welp
Oh boy. Oh boy. Okay hang on all right? Everybody hold on to your hats. Oh
That was very close slapper whoa
dangerous, huh
Got right off freakin puke egg right in the face all right
We got this okay, so far so good with the machine gun seems to be the better strategy for this when this poor part is
Heard this bird you heard damnit. I didn't mean to kill the slap a bird huh slap no
No easy easy easy easiest thing in the world. Yeah. Why did I go into that? Why is slapping?
You sack of shit here. I come you
Yeah, you better be toasty
oh
Well if I kill myself on the slap up in you ain't gonna even need to worry about me because I'm incredibly stupid my stupidity
Knows, no limits to be perfectly honest oh
God I was not paying it to slap by going from the flying mechanics to the - ah God
Why did I meant to?
Boom apparently oh boy. Oh boy. Oh boy. Oh boy. I'm gonna get that slapper, okay?
Oh jesus star - see ya you better. You better be tired no
No no no no come on now, what are you doing whoa?
Hard to see hard to see hard to see hard to see hard to see alright hard to see
Sassy so man is poor mother's sacrificing all of its children to try to be me BAM whoa
I walked right into that one. That was entirely my fault. I mean obviously everything I'm doing is my fault
Yeah, you better get mad. What are you gonna? Do get more mad? How you stupid a leg?
That's good doing it. Good for you slap got the slap
Slap your baby. Oh, no. It's just whoo hey no need for that Wow oh hi, baby
I thought I'd kill her your baby, but apparently not huh boom there. You go Hey wow?
This seems hazardous Hey whoa I could have slapped with that, but I just I let you go. I went easy on you
Yeah
God damn it. I'm not paying attention for the slapper. This is stupid babies is distracting me
Ah stop you frickin mastermind douche it's our dad
No, I was always looking right at it. Oh damn it okay?
My dad to the Brawn, and I'm all brains together. We bring the pain except your dad now
Sorry
All right, I got this easy-peasy
Yeah, yeah, yeah your stupid tantrum tramp
See this is the sort of stuff that I can deal with I can deal with I can deal with like bullet-hell
Dodges like this is this totally fine for me well
I mean I say that and watch I'm I'm about to be hit because I'm gonna try to go for the slapper and I did
It come on shoot me shoot me good. Slap. Thank you for the the power I
Went the wrong way oh, no, I got it, I got too close for the yeah for the shootie. Oh my god
Oh god damn. It well for some reason. I just am not paying attention to that when I should
Yeah, doing good though doing good though doing good though making progress come on come on come on you big bird bastard
Just give my bobbed what I?
Can mi sorry that was a disappointing thing
I'm just as disappointed as you guys are all right come on you big bird bastard. Just eat my bombs you bird bastard you banana
bulging beep
I said the sensor because it was saw days is what I said slap slap
How do you feel about this shit bomb oh god?
I've ran right into it didn't even think about my dodge wow I am an idiot
Tall man idiotic Pichardo boink didn't fancy can fancy fancy feet. Oh ah ah that's what I pay for my fancy feet there we go
boink and slapper Oh, doh
All right you you brain
You pinky and the brain wannabe you brain pinky half a doodle-doo
Slapping me slap. Oh very good whoa?
Okay, come on. Give me another give me a slap. Okay. Well you are about to feel the wrath of the bomb
Oh yeah, oh no, what's gonna do now you're gonna. Call on papa. Oh shit II called on Papa hey. Hey hey
Oh, you didn't I didn't know you're gonna split up there. Ah shit. God damn it every time
I go see a new area every time ah come on nuts slap damn
You made me miss the slapper you make me not kill one of your children
How could I shit you got me there that was that was a good one you definitely got me there oink?
That needle all right you're gonna get it slap Sabbath bomb bomb bomb in your butts
Here we go here come the bombs
Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam
That's a whitey ever why do you what is your ah I didn't know it go diagonal either. Oh?
You stupid piece of shit? Oh you piece of shit? Oh, you're just escaping death now
Oh, you're just prolonging the inevitable you bird piece of poop. Oh, what's that? Oh super?
Super in your face. I'm sorry was that not supposed to happen on it up seemed like pre appropriate to me
Ah, I almost got fancy. I almost got fancy
No way no way I did not get hit by that that is bullshit my controllers broken my dad works at Nintendo
Oh, no it's this immediate abou Mitch
That sucks so bad for you. No way you got what do you up? We go? Ah no? Oh no. Oh no
There's bad place to be in and predicted
Object permanence is my strong suit poink. Oh. Yeah. Oh. Yeah. Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah, oh, yeah, oh good
Did you see how I dodged that bad boy. Did you see how I dodged that bad boy
Oh you saw how I dodged that bad boy. Did you not all right come on?
Whoa why Oh slap no miss me slapper. Okay? You know what I'm a I don't think I'm not getting up. What is that?
I don't know if that is but I like it
You bitch oh, yeah puts salt, that's horrifying they're putting salt on him, that's no good. That's that's actually terrible
That's that's horrifying. Oh God. Why would they doing that?
Why would they do that? That sounds? That's just awful? Oh my god?
See pretty good pretty good pretty good. Okay. Let's carry on a little bit you want more out of this what a rush
What a rush to be amazing. Oh, is that the other mausoleum. Wall-e warbles and son don't forget about son he's in there to
Death it is well. Oh. What are you doing? Who are you Doug?
Do so have you spoken with quadratus the watery being across the aisle
That is something few others can claim all right. Well, okay?
All right mausoleum - oh do I get to slap her?
Okay all right
Nope slapper or you want the slapper. Oh you're gonna get the slapper. Oh come on
Give me a combo here. Give me something to actually give me a challenge up slappa
slappa
What was that I saw that?
miss yeah
Okay, you can't escape from the slap-a- that's another thing that I'm good at not that I'm bragging
But if something goes off off screen I usually can keep track of it like
That's what I mean by object permanence. I saw that Oh two of them
Eh oh I thought I was gonna get both at once. No this is bad
I was pressing I was pressing my
markiplier get with it be gooder I
Got this right there got ya. Okay. Give me a my double. I know you got the double oh
Oh come on
No come
On I was focused on the ah
Ha I was focused on the other side. I was trying to be fancy again. I can't be fancy in this game god
I can't be fancy. Just so stupid god
I wish I wasn't dumb you guys know how dumb I am yeah, I wish I was not that not today
I don't know. I think just touch this urn. Oh, shit uh
Fancy fancy feet I don't know why if they just touch this urn
It's like the end of it this poor person got trapped in this urn and just like that's it we rubbed out of existence
Dan ah got to fur oh boy
Oh, I was so close everytime slappa slappa oh no slapper, okay, alright. Hey
Zoom if I knew I rooted around here. I could find something special for you, but I didn't know I'd get trapped again
Thanks for saving me a second time take this magical super art and Sal see if I can find in another
Thank you. I don't know why you're doing this for me
Are you like my grandma or something you grandma cup you Cup grandma you gram Cup, MA. Oh?
I got another super
Let's see what no let's see what this one is invincibility cross the astral plane and become invulnerable for a short time
Well that does seem useful
That does seem useful
But it's also a crutch, so I ain't gonna do that ain't gonna do that think I'm fine. Yeah, I'm fine
I'm fine without it. Okay, so anyway. That's all the time. I got for cuphead in this episode
Thank you everybody so much for watching. Let me know what you thought down the comments below
I'm gonna carry on with this very soon, so thanks again and as always I will see you in the next video.
Buh-bye!
*Crazy La Paint by MiniMusicMan*